I'm just getting the latest figures from
the NHS for the number of deaths and
cases in England further 828 people who
tested positive for coronavirus have
died bringing the total number of
confirmed reported deaths in England to
six thousand four hundred and eighty
three all usual caveats of course about
the time lag many of these deaths the
initial problem would have started
before the lockdown so there was that
lagging element here and of course also
problems with reporting when when the
death happened and when the medical
staff get around to actually reporting
it let's turn to our correspondent Helen
Anne Smith who's in the newsroom to
ponder on these latest figures at first
blush hello Dan it's looking like a big
daily figure yes it is Anna Colin and
and every day we sit here at roughly
this time and talk about the numbers and
how much they've risen or not and it's
just worth stating right up front we
have to remember that behind every one
of these numbers is a real person and a
real family going through a truly
horrific time but yes at first look it
does look like a big jump in England in
particular so in England at the total
number of people to have sadly lost
their lives to this terrible virus six
thousand four hundred and eighty three a
jump of eight hundred and twenty eight
just to put that in context yesterday
the jump was seven hundred and fifty
eight in Scotland their total death
sadly now three hundred and sixty-six
that's up seventy it's just worth saying
with these Scottish figures the Scottish
government are slightly changing the way
they report their numbers so yesterday
we were warned that the figure was sort
of artificially high yesterday it was up
74 so possible that today might also be
slightly artificially high because of
the way they're changing their reporting
and the figures for Wales as well 245
people totally now to have died up 33
and that's the biggest daily increase
we've seen from Wales now look it's it's
worth saying that each individual nation
in the UK released their figures
separately and we're obviously giving
those to you as we have them what we
also will give you when it comes through
is a sort of in inverted commas a total
figure from the Department for Health
and Social Care it's worth just
stressing that that total figure is a
little bit skewed because of the
different time frames of
which the different four regions report
but it is our best indicator as to where
we're at and as you rightly said in your
introduction there Colin we have to
remember that these numbers are not
people who died yesterday they're the
people who the NHS trusts reported
yesterday so there is a lag there as
well